jeune homme, qui es-tu, quel est ton nom,
je n'ai aucune trace de toi mais tu peux dire
cette prison, nous te mettrons dans ce couloir, qu'est-ce
qui te ramène à la maison, j'ai reçu un appel de
Shawshank, j'ai trouvé un enfant dans la cage, la
cabine de café ne le fait pas.  tu sais, comment ça va, mon grand,
il y a un endroit où les amoureux vont pleurer
Oh
[Musique]
et les gens disent que chaque
centimètre carré de cette ville est une ville solitaire, ok, un
séjour difficile est taché d'un péché, tu as
toujours pensé que le diable
n'était qu'une métaphore,
Dieu, aide-moi, je  je l'ai fait
et je te dis
quelque chose de mal
gamin,
tu l'entends maintenant tu n'as aucune idée de ce qui
se passe ici, fais
[Musique]